depuis tout à l'heure j'attends
j'entends tout le monde parler de
racisme
je suis désolé mais au fait la même
chambre face à la négrophobie qui fait
partie du racisme c'est l'hostilité
ça fait partie d'une race envers les
personnes noires parce que quand on
parle de racisme
ce monsieur qui est devant nous peut
dire il n'est pas raciste
aucun de ses salariés ne peut être
raciste parce que ses amis sont
africains et sénégalais vous comprenez
mais il peut être être non et raciste
c'est à dire qu' il n'est pas peut-être
dans une haine de race mais vis-à-vis
des noirs donc c'est des agressions
ciblées alors pour commencer je vois que
il ya un élu ou un député ici avec nous
mais nous interpellons l'état les
autorités françaises qui sont complices
aussi de cette montée de négrophobie en
france pour dire qu'il faut mettre en
place d'urgence les dispositifs
législatifs fait social pour lutter
contre la montée les actes de
négrophobie envers les personnes noires
de france et il faut le comprendre que
si les autorités continuent de faire les
aveugles ça va péter et nous disons que
ce monsieur ce qu'il raconte il raconte
des balivernes
ce sont des balivernes vous pensez que
le monsieur travaille et j'ai mis ce
monsieur raconte différents éléments
pour les voilà nous avons des
témoignages même avant d'arriver une
maman une africaine est parti dans son
restaurant commandé dans son restaurant
à peine il a il a bousculé ce mourad se
décérébrés que vous avez vu sur la vidéo
il l'a traitée de négresse calme mais
non je vous jure que c'est pas vrai
messieurs je ne vous ai pas coupé vous
ne me coupait pas la parole ensuite
plein de gens ont reconnu
mourad salariés non déclarés c'est pour
ça qu'il ne peut pas le reconnaître il
est venu il a fourni des images
regardez bien il a fourni des images
qu'on voit l'agression de se livrer s'il
était si on est que ça pourquoi n'est-il
pas pourquoi vous n'êtes pas venu avec
les images avant même l'agression de
tout ce qui s'est passé peut-être 30
minutes ou une heure avant dans votre
restaurant pour prouver que ce monsieur
pourquoi là si vous essayez de vous
dédouané alors le faire complètement
mais toutes les images voilà je vous
livre toutes les images la police m'a
demandé quinze jours de réquisition un
jour voir toutes les images pour y lever
leur donner toutes les images et où la
police a déjà identifié le personnage
elle sait déjà qui sait ça y est ou
est-ce que ce matin j'étais porté
plainte moi parce que forcément je vois
je sais que le livreur a été porté
plainte juste avant moi moi j'y suis
allée juste après et j'ai porté plainte
aussi contre x parce que je ne sais pas
qui est cette personne je veux juste
qu'on la retrouve et que cette personne
est le deuxième la deuxième personne sur
la vidéo qui ne prenaient même pas le
temps de venir en aide aux livreurs qui
fusent et travaille essentiellement à
toutes ces personnes ne travaillent pas
cher alors ils travaillent ou alors ils
sont malades pourquoi dans ce cas là
lui-même le dit écoutez vous vivez avec
votre mari alors comment se fait il que
dans la vidéo il dit tu habites là avec
ton mari
l'accord excusez moi du terme je vais te
jeu s'il ne travaille pas là comment se
fait-il qu'il connaît n'avait jamais
vous l'avez jamais vu au restaurant vous
moi j'y vais pas tout le temps en fait
mais bon quand vous attend vous l'avez
vous l'avez déjà vu ou pas lequel le
monsieur qui l'agresseur non